hello everyone when students first join
the engineering colleges especially the
nits and iits they come with the
expectation that if their school
teachers and especially their coaching
Institute teachers were so good then how
good must the professors of these nits
and iits must be but just after doing
one or two weeks of classes they soon
begin to realize that that expectation
is not really met because sometimes the
quality of teaching is not very good and
I can relate to this feeling from my own
personal experience having been a
student uh in the IIT system so from my
personal experience I've had the
privilege of attending lectures of
teachers who were simply superb it was
so good sometimes that I felt that why
did the period have to end I just wanted
to wanted the lecture to continue but on
the other end of the spectrum what what
happened was that sometimes it was just
physically painful for me to sit in the
class and in between in between these
two extreme ends of the spectrum there's
always a mixture of the good and the bad
and in this video I want to explore a
little bit on some of the negative
aspects of it some of the bad qualities
that are there uh so in this video what
I'm going to do is I'm going to uh
divide the discussion into three broad
sections first I'm going to explore
why does it happen that the quality of
teaching is bad sometimes of course but
why is it bad sometimes next I want to
discuss some of the criteria based on
which we can say that a teacher is good
or bad and finally I would like to
discuss a little bit on what students
can do if they genuinely find that the
teaching is not going well so let us
begin this discussion first by exploring
why the teaching quality is sometimes
bad now I'm going to uh place this
discussion in the context of the NIT and
the I but whatever I'm going to discuss
is absolutely true for some institutes
abroad also in fact for most institutes
abroad but let us just confine ourselves
to our country India so the primary
reason okay it's actually very simple
for uh for sometimes the bad quality of
teaching that you see the
provs we are not trained to be
teachers this is the simple and bare
truth
so the the way that we become provs is
by showing ourselves uh to be good at
research in our during our PhD during
our post doog and that's how we get
selected uh in fact quite a long while
ago there was absolutely no system at
the entry level at the selection level
of professors to uh to gauge anything
regarding their teaching now it is of
course uh in the last uh 10 years or so
uh the things have changed a little bit
and at least I know for the fact that in
uh most of the IES there is something
called a teaching seminar in addition to
the research research seminar but
there's always the emphasis more on the
research side so nobody can become a
professor at the IIT or the nits without
being a good researcher but there is
nothing really to
prove with regards to the teaching and
there is certainly no training for us to
become good teachers certainly not
before and even after joining there is
nothing like that so it's always like
you join an an Institute as a new
faculty member and then you are allotted
some course and then you expect to just
appear in the in front of a class of
students and start teaching and the the
expectation is that just because you
happen to be good at research just
because you happen to be a good student
in your own Student Life uh somehow
magically you'll also be a good teacher
that of course doesn't happen the other
reason is that the personal career
progress of the faculty members of us is
not actually dependent on teaching uh to
a great extent sure we are answerable if
we do not teach well at all but the bar
is not very high as compared to the
expectations that are there for us in
terms of our research output so it
doesn't really hurt us in a very selfish
we speaking uh if we don't teach that
well but if you don't do research
properly then it actually hurts us so I
think that is one of the reasons a major
reason why many people they do not give
that much attention to teaching because
it really doesn't help their career and
this is absolutely true and very
unfortunately so not just in India but
also abroad and and and the unfortunate
thing is that uh there is no uh no
effici ient way to distinguish between a
a professor who is putting a lot of
effort into his teaching as compared to
another professor who is just like uh
checking the bare minimum check boxes
which are required to maintain a decent
level uh and I have seen this from my
own thing that here at I kakur we have
the feedback system from the students um
and we have it out of a score of five
I've seen that while it is uh not so uh
difficult to maintain something just
above four but to go from 4 to 4.5 it's
really very difficult okay and if you
have to score above 4.5 and it becomes
really really difficult you have to
really pay attention to your teaching
you have to be really really very
proactive in helping the students and
taking care for your teaching that takes
a lot of time okay and I have seen this
from absolutely firsthand experience it
takes a lot of lot of effort uh let us
next uh look at at some of the criteria
based on which we can say somebody's
really good or bad okay because uh while
feedback from the students is certainly
an important thing but there are certain
uh golden standards which I feel uh
which based on which we can see
somebody's uh good or bad so first of
all uh regarding uh the ability of a
professor to organize and structure his
course so what are the things that are
expected uh so if I were a student I
would expect the uh the teacher to
organize his course in such a fashion to
structure his course in such a fashion
that all the important points of the
course of that semester wide course are
very uh cleanly very neatly laid out U
uh at the beginning of the semester so
when the tests are going to be held when
the assignments are due what is the
actual syllabus how much of it will be
covered when what is the actual lesson
plan week by week on a week by week
basis uh
then what are the tutorial sheets all of
these things are very well laid out okay
so this is the bare minimum I would
expect as a serious academically serious
student from my professor and you would
be surprised actually that this is like
the basic level so even this basic level
is not maintained by certain professors
it is not that they don't care about the
students but somehow in the rush of the
semester uh these things just don't
happen okay if you ask them whether they
think these are important or not they
will definitely say it is yes but when
it comes to their running of their own
courses sometimes they don't do it okay
uh and mind you I I try to do it to uh
to do these things to the best of my
ability but I have seen from my own
personal experience these are not that
easy to do these are very basic
requirements but to structure it
properly and to have a proper plan in
place at the beginning of the semester
you have to put in some proactive effort
and invest that time for it it and
believe it or not which is why I was not
able to make uh uh the Youtube videos
for the past couple of months uh because
there's always the mad rush of these
things anyway the next thing okay is
regarding the very important ability to
actually teach and communicate
effectively to explain the concepts so
no matter how much you may organize and
uh no matter how much a professor May
organize and structure his course very
nicely
but at the end of the day if he's not
able to stand in front of a class of
students and explain the concepts very
nicely to actually teach very well then
he cannot be said to be a good teacher
there is simply okay I have to put this
bluntly there is simply no substitute
for actually standing there in front of
the class and teaching in a genuinely
good way now uh it is it is of utmost
necessity for such a thing to happen
that the that the Prof Professor has the
requisite knowledge so he should know
the the lessons inside out that is a
given but in addition to that at this
high level it is also necessary that the
professor should be able to connect to
probably certain other courses for
example when I'm teaching mechanics of
solids uh I try to connect some at
sometimes to fluid mechanics uh maybe to
certain math courses also so these are
again certain basic things which is not
very hard to do but but uh I think these
are important uh furthermore in certain
engineering courses at least it is
important that the professor makes an
effort to connect the lessons to some of
the professional practices okay because
ultimately the expectation is that the
students will go out and uh be
Professional Engineers so why not start
doing this from the class itself now on
these counts I feel that most of the IIT
professors are more than knowledgeable
enough uh they they have the requisite
knowledge for doing all of these things
but somehow uh I feel that they are not
communicating their knowledge in an
effective way there are many people who
are senior to me probably they can
suggest better but uh before going to
class I myself spend quite a lot of time
so every before every 1 hour class I
find myself preparing for at least 1
hour or maybe even more than that uh uh
despite uh the fact that I have been
teaching these uh courses for quite a
few years now I have to put in that much
effort so I I I really do think that a
little bit of homework is absolutely
necessary on the part of the professor
also before going to class on the note
of effective communication uh I feel
that uh and I know that many students
feel that when the uh professors uh
teach from slides it is not really very
effective especially in courses which
are derivation based which are
uh uh which involved a lot of maths uh
even in the engineering courses so if
the professors are relying on the slides
then what happens the pacing is somewhat
uh too Speedy that the professor just uh
runs through the the syllabus without
having ensured that the student has
actually picked up on the concepts uh
but if we do this on on the on the
Blackboard on the chalkboard uh the the
place all automatically gets slowed down
a little bit and we can uh actually
gauge what students uh are actually
picking up or not even then it is
difficult I know from first and
experience but probably for derivation
based courses slides are not the best
way to go uh and this is something which
I know students have quite a strong
opinion about also of course I know at
the same time that for certain courses
for example in manufacturing uh within
mechanical engineering there are certain
courses which involve lots of
complicated diagrams and it is not very
realistic to expect that the professors
will draw those diagrams there are some
legendary professors who can manage to
do it uh but uh it is not always very
realistic within the limited time that
we have in the semester to complete the
cabus in that fashion so in those types
of courses yes the slides may be uh
necessary on a completely uh different
uh but related note what i' would like
to say is that regarding this explaining
teaching and
communication uh no matter how much one
can prepare I had said that uh people
need to professors need to do a little
bit of homework before going to class
but no matter how much of preparation
they have done ultimately when they
standing in front of a group of students
and teaching there will inevitably be
certain times when the students will ask
something which are completely off
tangent and uh the the professor
necessarily has to uh think on his feet
and utilize that those moments those
unique moments as uh very good uh
teaching opportunities so that is I
think how an organic connection can be
made between the professor and the
student but this is something which is
not so easily done it is I mean this
kind of an ability to think on one's
feet uh in front of uh of a big class uh
and um and really turn these moments
into teaching opportunities it it is
kind of a gift some professors can do it
very very well Ive I've had the
privilege of attending those kinds of
classes also uh and I feel that uh
people who are genuinely active in
research they have a greater ability to
do these kinds of things okay so uh
there is always this uh debate of
research versus teaching but uh in
certain aspects I think the research can
actually inform the teaching also and
I'm sure many of students will agree
with me on this point uh and this is how
probably uh we can
distinguish uh the quality of teaching
at a great place from a not so great
place uh I'll leave it at that uh going
to the next Point uh which is that
another criteria for a good teacher is
that uh is his ability to actually
inspire his students what I mean by that
is
uh uh so this is at a slightly higher
abstract level is that beyond the actual
nuts and bolts of the teaching beyond
the organization everything uh a good
teacher a great teacher actually will be
able to inspire his students to kind of
fall in love with the subject to take up
projects in the subject and maybe even
go for higher studies or take up a truly
truly genuinely professional practice in
that area so those kinds of teachers are
rare but it is but they are there
they're very much there but on the flip
side I would say that sometimes there
are certain teachers who are very good
at uh saying goody goody things in class
and saying high-fi things but they do
not fulfill those basic uh things like
organizing the course properly
structuring their courses giving the
problem sheets and just saying goody
goody things so that doesn't work also
okay so you can go to that higher
abstract level of sparing the students
for going into higher and better things
but only have first uh done the basic
level things properly this is my my two
cents worth of opinion okay uh so after
all of this discussion what I would what
I would like to uh discuss in very short
is that uh if the students find that the
teaching is not going very well what can
they do okay because this inevitably
happens with every one I face this two
as I've already said uh what to do in
that case well when we were students we
were so very shy and kind of I mean too
respectful to the teacher that we that
we did not do anything that's the sad
truth okay uh we never gave any feedback
to the teacher not to anybody else like
what was happening in the class in those
courses that should not happen Okay so
my suggestion is that uh students if
they find that the teaching is not going
very well they should give some feedback
to the teacher in a very polite fashion
in a very respectful fashion and you
would be very surprised as students to
find that uh actually some teachers they
would be grateful if they kind if they
get this kind of feedback so uh for
example here at I karur we have the
system of feedback from the students but
that only happens at the end of the
semester so uh of course when the
students give some feedback uh and even
if the professor is receptive to
constructive criticis ISM he can mend
his ways but he can only do so for the
next batch of students so for that batch
of students the already the damage has
been done so while something is going
wrong I think it is a good idea for the
students if they detect that something
really is going on if they not
understanding in class maybe just take
it up with the uh teachers in a very
respectful fashion and give some
feedback that why they are not
understanding in class maybe something
which the teacher can slightly tweak in
his approach of teaching in his way of
communicating with the students or
interacting with the students during the
class uh that can make a a world of
change okay that can bring about a world
of change this is not something uh
drastic that I'm suggesting but uh I
have seen in my experience that uh
students sometimes just Crib in front of
other professors that okay this is not
going good I cannot understand but what
good is it if you complaint to some
other uh faculty members or maybe your
faculty adviser uh it is just better if
you directly take it up with the teacher
with whom um you're facing the
difficulty so on these points uh I'll
close this video I'm sure there will be
many many other points which students
will feel very strongly about uh I would
be very very happy to see uh those kinds
of points discussed in the comment
section uh and um let's hope that um
this video is a small step forward
in bringing about a better teaching
culture so thank you very much all the
best